Las Vegas to Los Angeles where the
annual Electronic Entertainment Expo
where III is gearing fans up for new
releases like cyberpunk 2077 this is the
latest team-up between Microsoft and CD
Projekt RED it's getting the star
treatment in its latest trailer take a
look at this
Gotham Samurai we have a city to burn
yeah so that little bit came at the end
of the trip the very long trailer for
the new game and Reese's character is
called mr. fusion and the actor actually
surprised the crowd at the Expo when he
showed up on stage she get me riled up
for the release date which is April 16th
2020 is set in a metropolis of the
future where body modification has
become an obsession you play as an
outlaw and enhanced mercenary working in
the sleazy underbelly of this city yeah
okay let me tell you the feeling of of
being there of walking the streets of
the future is really going to be
breathtaking
[Applause]
best he's the best yes the faith on
YouTube says I love keno it's time for
his time he's an underrated actor and is
amazing and Valeska over on Facebook
says any year is the year of cannon this
is what Canada's though he comes and
goes I know but please like no big deal
Kanto back but I think that Keanu Reeves
is especially the last couple years with
John wick and just how sort of
self-aware he is of his place in that
world and the world of show business and
that he showed up in always be my maybe
too he's a mean generating machine right
now it's unreal yeah I think that Keanu
Reeves is in that sort of stratosphere
now in show business with Tom Hanks
where you would have to search you could
spend a lifetime searching for anyone to
say anything bad about Keanu Reeves or
that they don't like him or like working
with him or that he's not the guy that
he appears to be and there's very few of
those people piano is definitely one of
them yes and it's almost like it's
banned generations like you still have
people talking about him working with
him on the matrix on speed and all they
can say is nice things and as far as
always be my maybe that scene with him
was the best part of that film yes
like I rewatched it yeah I went back and
won yes it was it was so good and it's
one of those scenes where you're like
one how did they even get him to do this
so I can't believe he's doing this and
three why couldn't the whole movie just
be good yeah now the crowds at e3 aren't
the only people excited about Keanu Toy
Story four stars Tom Hanks and Tim Allen
admitted that they were a little scared
of Keanu when they sat down with
Sangeeta Patel over the weekend while so
we'll be talking about do kaboom
[Music]
Canada I laughed my head off when they
said this is a new character it's called
do kaboom yeah he's the one beer number
one stuntman I said I'm a daredevil well
we don't I I did not meet Keanu Roos
until we took a picture with a whole
cast about a month ago we don't you
don't work together I was terrified to
work with him he I just saw John wick
four or three I go good lord I don't
want to get this guy upset keep them
away from the knives right there we go
they're all in the same world now that's
very cute Diana on Facebook says awesome
we just saw John wick and then her next
comment is he's very generous and caring
but I feel like she's obviously not
talking about as character in that film
correct right yes yes yes no key on but
key on oh bizarro key on oh and always
be my maybe is I would still love him if
that was the real key on Who I am I
really hope that that is real yeah I
know yeah